hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a fantasy film called the man
without gravity
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts as we see a woman named
natalia and her mother alina drive
through a storm to the hospital the
woman is in labor in pain she begs her
mother to drive quickly when they reach
the hospital a nurse at the reception
informs them that no doctors are
available at the moment
so she herself helps the woman natalia
finally gives birth but the baby doesn't
cry
in fact he floats in the air like he is
lighter than it the three are stunned
natalia grabs the umbilical cord and
gently pulls him towards her
natalia and her mother run away with the
newly born without providing their
information to the nurse
natalia is over the moon to birth such a
special child she assumes that her baby
is an angel
at home natalia assumes that if he eats
something he will stop flying alina asks
her who the father is but it turns out
that natalya doesn't know because she
was a prostitute alina then declares
that the child will not be allowed to
leave his home she wants to protect the
baby from the cruel world outside
the following morning alina wakes up to
the child sleeping on the ceiling she
carefully brings him down
the two name him oscar
just then four friends of elena arrive
at their door to have a look at the
newborn
natalia ties the baby to a crib with a
belt and covers him with a blanket the
women do not suspect anything one of
them tries to pick oscar up but alina
doesn't let her saying that the baby is
fragile the women then leave
the two then make the house's ceiling
comfortable for the child so he can
sleep freely alina tells people that
oscar is allergic to the sun so he
cannot come outside
cut to a few years later oscar has grown
up into a beautiful child now
he is still not allowed to go outside
the house by his grandmother
his everyday life includes looking at
people through the window and watching
batman on tv
alina also teaches him to read and write
at home
one day natalia makes him a jacket with
weights on its pockets this makes oscar
able to walk on the ground
natalia is happy because now she can
send her son to school
however alina is against him leaving the
house for his own safety
even when natalya insists alina doesn't
budge
one day oscar is alone in his house when
he opens the window and tries to get out
of it when alina and natalya come back
they are shocked to see the window open
initially they thought oscar had run
away from home but apparently oscar's
jacket had fallen off him and he was
stuck in the ceiling
not taking any chance further alina
starts to shut the windows permanently
but natalia has had enough she wants her
kid to go outside and look at the real
world she fights with her mother and
takes oscar outside that night while on
their walk she tells him to keep his
power a secret to keep himself safe from
the bad guys he limps while walking as
he hasn't walked that much in life
that day onwards natalya starts to take
him out every day in his jacket they
walk hand in hand natalia even teaches
him to walk better one day natalia and
oscar are shopping when she leaves oscar
outside a store
while he waits he bumps into a little
girl named agata and drops her groceries
the little girl is mad at him and asks
him to help her carry the groceries to
her house
at first oscar hesitates but then he
agrees to help her carry bottles
the two walk away from the store
they talk about several different things
on their way after they walk for a while
oscar is tired because of the weights in
his pockets so he throws them out the
weight of the bottles keeps him on the
ground
but when they reach agatha's home she
asks him for the bottles
knowing that he will fly away without
them oscar refuses the two tug the
bottles then eventually drop them
since the weights are gone oscar flies
up but thankfully is stopped by a roof
the little girl assumes that he is a
superhero and watches him in awe
she gives him her backpack so that he
can stay on the ground and promises to
not tell anyone
natalia is at home
worried to death about her son
just then he comes home running
he tells his mother about his new friend
when asked if she knows about oscar's
powers he lies and says that she doesn't
from the following day agatha and oscar
play together she comes to oscars every
day for playdates
one day agatha's grandmother brings her
over as natalia and she talk natalia
realizes that agatha knows about oscar's
abilities so she doesn't allow oscar to
play with her from the next day agata
visits oscar's house every day but
natalya always makes up an excuse to
send her away
one day agatha brings her grandmother to
oscars natalya dismisses them saying
that oscar has to do homework but agatha
reveals that oscar doesn't go to school
the grandmother along with other ladies
in the town calls the police to
natalia's house they demand natalia and
alina to admit oscar to a school the two
agree
it is now oscar's first day at school
natalia takes him in but realizes that
the kids are supposed to keep their
backpacks and overcoats outside
saddened she brings him back to the car
and they come back home
they finally decide to move to a remote
town to avoid anyone checking on oscar's
condition
cut to a few years later oscar is all
grown up now alina had passed away the
mother and the son have moved to the
mountains and live a normal life there
oscar always has his backpack with him
one day oscar sees an advertisement on
the tv about a talent show the announcer
urges everyone with a unique talent to
audition for the show
he wants to take part in the show to
showcase his talent so he decides to
leave the town without telling his
mother
a few days later oscar is at the talent
show where he shows everyone his flying
abilities
everyone is amazed
some assume that oscar is an angel
oscar attracts the attention of a talent
scout named david who offers oscar to be
a celebrity david tells him that he will
be called to tv shows to showcase his
talent oscar's biggest dream is to have
a book written about him and david
promises to make that happen
without hesitation oscar signs a
contract with david then david gives him
the title a man without gravity is his
stage name after signing the contract
david gives him a luxurious house as a
gift he wants his mother to stay in the
house as well but david forbids it the
next day oscar starts performing on tv
shows and appearing as a model in
magazines
as he keeps flourishing initially he
loves the fun city life but gradually he
starts feeling empty and bored he starts
gaining a lot of fans to make oscar even
more famous david deliberately creates
false stories about oscar he even makes
a museum about oscar where he displays
random items as his belongings to profit
off them
later oscar protests about the media
spreading false information about him he
doesn't want to live his life like this
anymore
he is bored of the celebrities life so
he asks david to terminate the contract
but just then david mentions a publisher
wanting to meet david to write a book
about him
hearing this he changes his mind his
dream of getting a book written about
him is finally coming to life he is
beyond delighted
however when he goes to meet the author
and the publisher he gets to know that
they are just interested in selling as
many books as possible for profit they
want to exaggerate his life story
painting him as extremely poor in his
childhood and adding false stories
hearing this oscar refuses to work with
the publisher
the following day david invites oscar's
mother over because he knows oscar
misses her she arrives to a party going
on an oscar's home
natalia has brought motivational quotes
oscar used to collect back home
natalia is delighted to see her son but
oscar is visibly sad
the next day oscar makes a mistake while
appearing on a live tv broadcast
david is furious at him
oscar reveals that he doesn't want to be
the man without gravity anymore he asks
david to fake his death so he can live a
peaceful life the news spreads like
wildfire everyone talks about oscar's
death journalists come to oscar's house
every day to try and interview his
mother
days pass an oscar has changed his
identity to deskee
he changes his appearance and pretends
to be handicapped so he can tie himself
to a wheelchair when going outside
desk is now working as a receptionist at
a hotel famous for prostitutes
one christmas eve every room is empty
except for one
desky goes to check on the person in the
room
he finds the new prostitute there who
tells him everything is fine as he is
about to leave the woman calls deskee by
his real name oscar oscar is surprised
as it turns out that the woman is agatha
she has started working as a prostitute
they are very happy to finally meet
again
the next day they go on a date and talk
about many things from their past
at night they come back to oscar's room
and have sex
they actually love each other but agatha
still hesitates to accept oscar's love
because of her profession
they get into a huge fight about the
situation and oscar leaves
the next day oscar goes back to his old
town to see that the place has been
deserted the museum they open to display
oscar's belongings has been closed too
he goes inside his old house and stays
there for a while when suddenly someone
knocks on the door
it is agate addressed as her younger
self
seeing her like that oscar smiles
cut to a few years later oscar and
agatha are married and live in oscar's
childhood home
agate is pregnant with their child
oscar has started working as a window
cleaner the movie ends as we see oscar
dresses up as batman
cleaning a skyscraper's window he is
living his childhood dream
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching